we are mourning the loss of one of our
own longtime CB s communications chief
Gill Schwartz a legend in this industry
died Saturday of natural causes
Schwartz retired as senior executive
vice president and chief communications
officer at CBS Corporation in 2018 CBS
said in a statement for the better part
of three decades Gill Schwartz led CBS
communications with creative flair
craftsman like expertise and an
abundance of personality Schwartz was
also known for his sharp wit and humor
while working for years as a columnist
and author under the pseudonym Stanley
Bing he wrote three novels and 13
business books in 2017 he spoke to us
about how the idea of living forever
inspired his most recent novel immortal
life a soon to be true story I'm not as
young as I used to be and and I would
like to live forever and I think a lot
of people when they get to the age you
could be 40 and suddenly you realized
wow you know what it would be really
nice to line extend my life Gil Schwartz
is survived by his wife Laura for kids
and stepkids and grandchildren he was 68
years old this was a real shock Gail I
have to say 68 years young we should say
and he was talking about immortality
right there and and Gil was a real
renaissance man he was he was a poet a
playwright an actor he did improv I mean
a really extraordinary guy all of the
above I spent time with him you know
he's been on our show a couple of times
he had a unique sense of humor used to
watch us all the time and always had
lots to say